on a fait ici une petite table avec le
coup de coeur donc toutes les meilleures
lectures de l'équipe librairie depuis
trois mois les saint quentinois peuvent
découvrir l'offre culturelle proposée
par l'enseigné furet du nord
un réseau de 17 magasins répartis dans
le nord et en ile-de-france à skywest on
peut y trouver 40 mille références de
livres et 15 mille produits loisirs
chaque jour on a de nouveaux clients
donc c'est chouette de voir que une
vraie progression tous les jours et on
est très contents de nos résultats
jusqu'à présent avec des week-ends avec
beaucoup beaucoup de familles qui
viennent des vacances scolaires qui
fonctionne super bien
en plus de la littérature lancel s'est
diversifié ces dernières années avec des
produits de loisirs créatifs du
multimédia de la papeterie ou encore des
jeux pour enfants une offre qui s'étend
ici sur près de 2000 m² nous sommes
venus au cinéma et on a vu cette
enseigne nouvelle donc voilà c'est une
découverte
la première impression c'est l'espace
quand on passe devant la porte laborde
l'impression que ces petits séance de
dédicaces démonstrations de jeux
ateliers de loisirs créatifs
l'enseigne mise également sur
l'événementiel pour attirer la clientèle
qu'elles soient adultes ou plus jeunes
c'est très important pour nous de faire
vivre à nos clients différentes
expériences en magasin les gens sont
très demandeurs
et là notre prochain événement c'est la
nuit harry potter pour les 20 ans de la
sortie du livre harry potter on organise
tout un tas d'animations dans le magasin
a commencé par une cérémonie de
répartition avec le choixpeau pour
savoir dans quelle maison on va être
envoyée donc il ya des êtres des
ateliers qui sont pour les plus grands
mais aussi pour les plus jeunes
son communiqué de chiffres le magasin
furet du nord à skywest confie avoir
atteint ses objectifs
après trois mois d'ouverture